I want to know what the Teen Mom star
Jenelle Evans has temporarily lost
custody of her three kids
what et has learned that a judge made
the temporary decision in North Carolina
on Tuesday which removes Jenelle's legal
rights over her three young kids sons
Kaiser and Jace and daughter Ansley
who she shares with her husband David
Eason our source says Jason and Lee are
currently with Jenelle's mom Barbara
we're also told that David is still not
allowed to see his daughter Marissa from
a previous relationship a rep for
Janelle tells e.t quote at this time we
are cooperating with the judge and legal
team from court we will continue to
cooperate with the court and their
decisions Jenelle and David are expected
in court June 4th although there's no
official confirmation as to why Jenelle
lost custody of her little ones the news
comes just two weeks after some major
drama went down on May 14th an insider
told ET that Jenelle's sons had been
removed from her custody by Child
Protective Services
after David allegedly shot and killed
their French Bulldog nugget good you
should be a reality star seemingly
confirmed that he killed the dog by
posting a now-deleted video showing the
animal appearing to be aggressive with
their daughter he wrote in the caption
in part quote I don't give a damn what
animal bites my baby on the face some
people are worth killing or dying for
and my family means that much to me
earlier this month
MTV told ET they entered their
relationship with David in February 2018
after he posted a number of homophobic
and transphobic tweets
if you're gonna yell at me as for
Janelle they said they have no plans to
work with her in the upcoming season of
Teen Mom 2 what are we gonna do
[Music]
[Applause]